you
[Music]
this morning I'm going to talk about
building a linearized startup or a
subtitle this how to start an ml company
in your garage which is where we had the
experience of doing a couple years ago
so yeah I'm the co-founder and CTO of
Matt Kudo what is Matt could do it is a
lead coin company that basically enables
b2b companies to customize the journey
of a customers at scale and everywhere
so this is the list of some of our
customers which we pretty proud of about
50 customers as of today what is lead
scoring and what do we do differently is
tentacle it you know machine learning
for sales and marketing but really what
we're trying to do is to add voice
company have you no information about
the customers and knowing if they're
good potential customers or good
customers at every stage of the sales
and marketing funnel so in practice what
that means is we try to integrate with
everything so from marketing automation
with folks like
mockito UPS but reach obviously the CRM
lots of sales force but also fresh sales
pipe drive and a couple others we
integrate with your live chat as well so
for example if we identify that a
visitor to the website can be a good
lead and you know you can decide on the
spot to pop up a demo request and also
now we going into looking at optimizing
advertisement using that information as
well so we integrate with the entire
value flow on sales and marketing an
interesting thing I think about a lot of
US customers is a lot of those customers
have data science and you know an ml
team and they still ended up I think
working with us mostly because of an
integrated aspect across the value cycle
so before we got those customers my
co-founders and I started as you know
small experience as data scientist and
product manager we started with no
funding at all for the year and working
from this actual garage it got really
warm and summer I would not recommend
that if you can you can avoid it and you
know this days the garage not even
actually cheap in Silicon Valley so not
a great thing but what I'm going to talk
about today is basically about you know
I think the talk is really for people
here if you're looking at starting a
company or have an email id or something
that you're like oh cool I would like to
bring that into the world or launch a
new product and you know you don't
necessarily have a ton of
intrapreneurial experience and lot of
cash on and how can you do that without
you know spending your entire first year
just building the email part so I have a
bit into how you can try being a lean
with AI and m/l some practical lessons
we learned and things we did to iterate
quickly and I think you'll I said focus
on the product engineering with a side
of go to market but as I did the slide I
think it's going to be a bit more of
like good to market and eye level
practices so now this was really a lot
of engineering but I happy to chat about
that aspect in office hours afterwards
all right so if you remember this is
trying to be actually quite old I looked
it up and the lean startup starting
coming up in 2008-2009 so it's actually
about a decade old is days but you're
probably familiar with the build measure
learn there's been a lot of stuff
mentioned about that stuff but you're
basically trying to do the thing which
is how can I go fast into dominating a
market it's kind of like the general
idea what's what's different
quick note that ethic will do the I will
use data science machine learning and AI
a bit interchangeably in that talk have
been confused by the marketing I know
they're not the same but I think it's
not you know
Vica when we started we call we used to
call it data science and now we call it
AI for marketing purposes gonna use it
interchangeably don't eat me for it but
so ya build measure learn and the
question I think we add as a ok what's
what's different with it's very anything
different with you know building in the
eye or building a machine learning
product I think the main learning is
it's generally harder right I think if
you just try to like build measure learn
you will figure out like a okay what do
I build I found this stuff from an
article from I think is that a venture
did a lot of pretty cool work on that
subject she's a venture fund for focus
mostly on the eye product but what you
want to prove I think with your early
product is three things the first one is
you want to make sure that the problem
you're solving is actually solvable with
AI or machine learning which means
really two things that you can curtain
that you can collect and get the right
data and then that you can predict you
know slightly better than what a human
could do or that an existing system
could you over a simple heuristic could
you the second thing you can do which is
different from the first one though it
is well it's someone actually gonna buy
this or it's going to be useful because
this is a category of product where you
can completely do the first one but then
no one cares and I'll come back to that
a little bit later and the third one is
okay that solvable someone's interested
but can you actually solve this over
time in the right circumstances so this
is a framework that the folks at setup
put together which I wish I had seen you
know three four years ago when we were
getting started
which is actually a little odd to see so
I'll read I read it but it's sort of a
pyramid of building an AI /ml product so
at the bottom you have capturing the
training data level above is training
the model to what they call minimum
algorithmic
performance above that you're gonna test
the model in real life then you want to
capture a feedback data measure the RI
and package it appropriately so what
they show what the left from the right
is basically what you want to avoid
doing is just doing one horizontal layer
and spend your time there what you need
to actually have a successful product in
the IO ml is go through the entire you
know the entire pyramid basically and
what's a bit missing from that graph is
you probably want to do circles around
that cycle to make sure that you know
you get you get the entire value
interestingly on the graph they
highlighted the test model in real life
if you like me and your data scientist
or something you might spend a little
too much time I think on the one below
the Train model to algorithmic
performance for example if you're a data
scientist if you're in the tie engineer
you might spend a lot more time on
capturing data and serving it so each
one might have a bias I think the point
of the point of this and the main lesson
we learn building this is how do you
make sure you go through those steps as
soon as possible so you can make sure
that in the end someone wants to buy
your AI product so what I'm going to do
next is I'm going to go a little bit
through each of those steps and sort of
errors or issues we made errors we made
while going through them and some of the
basically lessons we learned in building
this so first step pretty simple on
paper but as most of you probably know
as the big catch-22 of of building data
products is are do I get data you as we
mentioned you need data to prove that
your problem is solvable and you need
data to get feedback I think that's a
very important one I think you know main
difference with regularly installer
boats there you'd have a lot of advice
on I'll just build a mock-up go show it
to your customers and get feedback I
think if you tried that and if you've
already built like a dashboard or some
some sort of product
for example my my finding is that it
does not work for data product if you
want to get feedback for a data product
you need the customers actual data or
some approximation of it like I've seen
I've seen this going gun good to way if
you go to the markup approach it might
be someone's like oh yeah that's cool
you know I want that and then you build
a real version and I know if it's a
dashboard maybe just doesn't move over
time or it you know like you know you
always do this mock-up of dashboards
that show cool stuff and impressive
results because obviously that's what
you're gonna put on the markup and then
you try it with real data and it's a
flatline and you're like great okay the
opposite might actually happen which is
something that the customer might say
well maybe and then you show it with the
real insights and they're like oh wow
well I want that right so I think that's
an important difference with the actual
you know with the old-school lean
startup is how you know to mock it up I
think you need to have some level of
data right so obviously that's the big
the big catch-22 is you don't have a
product how do you get a customer to you
know give you data so you can get
started I think if you're a big if
you're a big company sometimes you get
out of that and you're launching a new
product you get out of that conundrum
because you're already capturing that
data for other applications and you
manage to get access to you know someone
in recommendation what capturing that
data and you can build another
application on top of that if you're a
startup well you can't really do that
because you have nothing existing so
what what worked for us on that aspect
is um I think we spent I call it like
it's a lot of like smoke and mirrors but
basically make it as easy for your
customers to send you the data that
sounds pretty obvious but it's almost
like 90% of the engineering we did is
like okay it's super easy for the
customer to send us the data and then
it's really hot and really manual for us
to do the things afterwards but don't do
the reverse right you want to make it
simple - - for the customers like oh
yeah sure I'd like to try this ok
one-click how can you get that data so
that they don't
- you know gonna start then they're not
going to be able to say Oh show I'll you
know I'll assign the team for like four
weeks to make you an extract from the
data warehouse and blah blah blah right
so you want to make that super easy we
did that is one was partnering with
existing data repositories so I think
for us in sales and marketing it was
relatively obvious because like most of
the data already lives in Salesforce and
macchiato and up spot so we add access
to those other sources of data I'm sure
for other products there might be other
things one thing we did that you know is
a little tricky but dangerous is at the
beginning you not sure what you're gonna
need so if you can get a little more
than you need it's usually a good
recommendation right so don't you know
be a little greedy on what you ask at
the beginning if you get access because
that will let you iterate at the margin
relatively easily another one that's
really more on the go-to-market side but
it's finding the right size of customer
I think if you know your first customers
ask you for an entire legal review and a
month to get you the data that might not
be the right size to get started you
sort of want you know if in our case I
think I was partnering with companies or
you know add one or two data engineers
that were able to maybe set a few things
up or connect you know connect
applications but if you get into a team
but as it's too large that might take a
little too long yeah so a couple of
couple of fun stories from Smoke &
Mirrors the smoke and mirrors is this
example is I think we we were lucky
enough to integrate with segments great
application for you know great source of
data analytics if you can build an
integration with them I think these days
they're a little more strict about what
they allow as integration I think we
came at the point when we submitted the
application it was a no GS API endpoint
that would actually do nothing with the
data but returned the 200 you got that
on the marketplace and then we build the
pipeline
afterwards but that means that as soon
as possible you know our customers could
start sending us data and we could
figure out what
to do with it afterwards so it was
pretty cool of them really liked them
for letting us do that the other
interesting anecdote about that one is
that endpoint in no dgs that sends data
to ask us I think
Ezrin change in three or four years it
was pretty actually easy to build um the
data get it in a data lake and then you
can figure it later what to do with it
for the Salesforce integration it was a
bit of the same it was a UI page where
you could enter you know you could do
the OAuth flow to connect well
salesforce would say if the access token
to the database and then we're like okay
cool now we can explore what's in
salesforce and see if we can find things
to predict so couple caveat for that one
is actually go to that one is use some
of your early engineering a force if you
gonna ask for too much data use some of
your early engineering efforts to
protect it correctly because obviously
the thing you want to avoid is getting
that data and then losing it that would
usually be the Deaf the deaf case for
any startup you want just you want to
ask for just in you know if you are it's
like one of those you know oh I think
it's lag but you know if a slack
application ask you for access to all
your messages you might say like if it's
a little bit too much so ice for a
little bit more than what you need but
not not too much on the partners under
channel I think it was kind of the same
thing it was finding the partners of the
right size for us at that time example
we had a terrible experience with
existing repository like Marketo Eloqua
we introduced another catch 22 which is
you have to prove them that you have
customers before they let you become a
partner and you don't have customers so
how do you get out of that catch-22 is a
little bit tricky but if you can find
you know for your AI product and you're
looking at integrating with existing
sources of data would recommend that you
look at someone who's in the right-sized
I will not have you know too much red
tape they won't let you take that data
out but that's so good you know that's a
good trick that worked for us to you
know get data to build that ml product
second
is actually getting you know getting
predictive this one I think if you're a
data scientist or engineer and you're
thinking you're gonna you you're
starting a startup you're like well I
know I know I'm you know I know I'm
probably gonna spend too much time on
this I'm gonna avoid that problem I'm
not gonna be one of these guys I think
you're still gonna be one of these guys
it's extremely tricky to not spend too
much time on that step in my experience
right I mean you've experienced doing
data science you're gonna be like oh
cool
how can I you know I can I improve that
model really I should be able to get
better results what if I use tensor flow
chaos or whatever so you know it but
still you know maybe tape tape something
on your wall that says you know don't
optimize too much your model too early
um a couple dead ends I think oh I
didn't finish that slide then one dead
end what I mentioned that is I think one
dead end we encountered was trying to
predict churn was our initial you know
business idea where in sort of ad space
I think there's some one term or with a
talk about predicting churn which I'm
really interested in seeing the reason
I'm saying that is I think Schwerin is
really good you can do we you can
predict churn on a data set and you can
spend a lot of time getting better
results the reason I would recommend not
to spend too much time on this is for us
we realize at the next step that you
know you can predict run on the data set
but then what can you do about it and we
couldn't find the next step of you know
getting actual use edge of good feedback
data I'm I'm willing to be convinced
otherwise but I still know that you know
if your model tells you that someone's
going to churn it might be too late to
do anything about it so traffic is
really good at this step you can spend a
lot of time optimizing at this step but
in our experience it failed at the next
one which is a no one actually wants to
pay for that or the you know the
feedback cycle the feedback cycle tells
you that you know people do not get ROI
from such an application so the point
here was like okay
model market fit and we didn't go fast
enough to sort of like the capture
feedback data and measure my steps
because initially you were like oh maybe
we can predict this better and by
predicting this better we'll get we'll
get better results so the the solution
that's proposed by Zetas and their paper
was basically find something I think
they try to find the ml equivalent of
the Minimum Viable Product which I think
I call minimum algorithmic performance I
think that's an interesting concept it's
an interesting concept to use I think
basically what this says is just try to
find the simplest model that does better
than the status quo and stop there
it's kind of its kind of the idea on
that one in our case that meant starting
with very very basic regression and
trees and not try any other things
before getting to the next step i would
i will also recommend not trying and
increasing too much the complexity of
the AI models but instead looking at can
i get more data or can I get more
dimensions in my data set and again this
is the moment that if you're an engineer
you should have every cell of your brain
that tells you to worry about
scalability modularity or any of those
things you'll get back to this if this
works step three which is the another
very interesting one is now okay now
you've got to the point where you've
gathered data you've trained the model
performs pretty well on paper okay now
what do you do with it and how do you
get feedback on that model and same
recommendation on that one I think on
this one I I wanted to find you know
errors we made I think on this one we
actually executed pretty efficiently by
because we didn't have a lot of
experience with data engineering so we
just figured out the the fastest thing
that worked which was SQL spring SQL
scripts running on cron that would just
refresh the data daily and we didn't
know anything else I'm like okay so we
didn't over complexify that one
I highly recommend testing a full
refresh batch model before doing any
kind of you know incremental logic or
real-time or streaming or whatever
because again what you want at this
point is showing the models your
customer and figure out if they're ready
to pay for you know the benefit it
brings them so I don't think there's a
lot of vendors of big data stack
technologies today as sponsors but I
might not make friends with them if
you're around is at this stage I don't
think you need a lot of spark Kafka or
any complex technologies if you know
them and you maintain you you know them
well and and you go fast you go as fast
with them as you would with any other
technologies absolutely you should use
them but if you don't I'm not sure
that's the right moment and that cycle
to really learn about them if anyone
upstairs you know you're like startup
founder three people four people five
people they're trying to sell you that
stuff up there at you know at the expo
well let me know because I want to talk
to them but probably not doing a good
job at lead scoring but that's it's a
different point so I would say like keep
like basically the the they're learning
at that step is keep things simple and
what we did then at the next step is
basically okay now you know you've
applied it you've refreshed your model
daily with the data coming in it's just
kind of like the personalization but you
want to keep that simple and then the
next step is basically how do you get
feedback from your customers I as an
engineer made that mistake early on
which is like oh cool you know I'm free
like we instrum we had instrumented the
model we were pushing scores basically
in Salesforce for customers and I'm like
okay done you know now I just need to
find other customers it turns out that
yeah they you know they were not really
looking at whatever we were pushing we
were pushing to them or we didn't know
if I was helping them or not so same
thing as an engineer that's actually the
moment that might be the most
complicated which is you know the moment
we're like okay
does this work and the best way to best
way still as in the Lean Startup to
figure out if something works for a
customer is to ask them for money really
interesting story on that on that front
from us was I think my co-founder tried
to my co-founder is doing sales for us
went to one of our early customers at
the moment tried to have that
conversation and I think we started the
conversation of yeah that's useful you
know and then oh would you you know
would you be ready to pay for it how
much and I think my co-founder started
that I don't know like $1,000 a month
nope
500 nope we ended up selling a first
deal at $50 a month but I was kind of
like eh okay maybe that's you know maybe
that's not creating as much value as we
thought it would so if you're building
that as part of a company that's not yet
making any money and you're trying to
proof fracture and make sure you ask
that question early one thing we did
early on was actually this kind of goes
back to the previous step but before
even instrumenting it we went just with
like a let's present a PowerPoint deck
with the results of the model and see
what they think I think this one depends
we got some good feedback on that one
but I would say it's it's a good it's a
good step to see if you're heading in
the right direction but you still need
to go serve the model where your
customer is going to use it right so it
doesn't matter if you have a model that
predicts well on your machine if say
you're our customer is a cell you know
main user is a salesperson or marketing
person they spend the day in Salesforce
well that's where the money that's where
the model needs to leave pretty much I
think initially you were like oh maybe
if we build another application and we
ask sales people to you know come and
see another application to see this cuz
I know not working the sales person
wants to be in Salesforce you want to
serve the model via and the last very
important step for us at that point was
like okay just serving it was not enough
if you wanna if you wanna really be
useful to a sales team or marketing team
you need to be integrated with the
process you need to be really embedded
and our using the product of a
I mean for us to be very concrete it is
okay I'm predicting that this person's
going to be a good lead does it affect
all the sales team and also them does
the sales team and all you know good
lead faster than bad leads does it
change anything do they know it exists
do they use it so as that step you know
that is very again kind of very annoying
for engineers or data scientists which
is okay the moment where you try to
train a sales or marketing team is not
something that's necessary and your job
in your project description but it's
very critical to make sure that you're
just not you know iterating in a vacuum
what's on that one on yeah that one was
an interesting one for me as well
because you know your data scientist
your model proves your model says you're
really confident that your model says
that this is a good lead and the
customers like no I don't think it's
good or ask questions about it why it
sucks but you're not going to win the
fight but say hey the algorithm says it
is initially I think you really have to
listen to that feedback and what we did
initially is okay let's let's let's just
override those things manually on top of
the actual models so that we can uncover
the next objection right if your
customer tells you I don't think that's
a good lead oh I don't think this
prediction is good might as well just
say let's go over that one and see okay
now if I make it better
does it work one way is just to override
the model and I think another learning
is that for I think that's always going
to happen in all scenarios I think for
sales team and marketing team it's
pretty obvious but we have you know we
have teams that do not sell in Asia for
example customers who do not sell in
Asia if you tell them by the customer in
Singapore is a really good customer and
they don't have a sales team there then
you know maybe that's not as good of
customer so make sure you take voice you
know you're a stick and business model
rules into account so you can get
feedback that matters this one's
returning the the last step in the
pipeline is
ROI it is extremely important I have
absolutely no recommendation on how to
do this I think we still we're figuring
this out but I have not generalized that
step it can be difficult I know that for
example with with churn for example is a
really good example churn is a big
problem so company but it's a small data
problems right you have you know I mean
you lucky if you're lucky you are lucky
if you have another 50 customers leaving
every month but it's very bad from a
trend perspective but from a number of
data points perspective it's it's really
small you're not gonna a B test that one
with a significant level of with a
signal
you know with any level of significance
right so sometimes a good thing to
remember so I'll have generalization on
on that one I think on
oh I we tend to you know actually not
necessary focus on accuracy of models
and stuff like that but almost on time
saved sometimes there's actually a
better metric is like I used to take me
a lot of time it takes me less time it's
not necessarily about returning better
better results or you know more accurate
more accurate decisions and the
interesting thing which I was mentioning
then it's missing from that entire
framework which otherwise really cool is
you'll probably need to go through that
cycle multiple times unless you're very
lucky and the first ID you have for you
for your mop for your you know AI
product works right from the start
you'll probably need to go over that and
try again a couple of tips that we
implemented to do this is I think the
the the trap here is to create structure
and abstractions too early so trap
because now I'm you know that's what
I've spent the last two years afterwards
doing is figure out the right structure
and abstractions so that you know my
company gets economies of scale from
implementing worse models but you don't
want to do at early on the rule like it
was actually a very explicit rule we
implemented initially it was called it
the rule of three not
not the most you know marketing friendly
name but let's wait until we've done a
thing for free clients before even
looking at building the abstraction and
then be very consistent about okay now
we've done free let's build the
abstraction that's going to let us go to
four five six but we always say like ok
we've done that for only one customer
let's not abstract the model let's not
abstract the component or the future
generation pipeline or things like that
so yes lots of spaghetti SQL that
basically what happens same thing as an
engineer I was like I don't wanna see
this but as a start-up founder I was
like this is actually necessary so be
careful of you know balancing your
instincts on that one and I have one
last slide which is on team organization
and I think if you thinking of getting
started we're launching an ml product I
would say this sounds really obvious but
I don't think that can succeed if you
don't have at least one founder that is
AI ml data science data engineering
practitioner I don't think you can go
through that cycle fast enough by also
sing it or having someone junior that
doesn't know doesn't know the product
because really you want to go fast and
mix the business you know mix the
business feedback into your development
loop for us I think I work pretty well
we have two founders we're background in
ml and one with experience in data
pipeline and data engineering so who is
actually the sort of like a right mix to
go through that cycle I think if you
have to make a trade-off
I would I would have the founder do the
data science piece and I are on data
engineering but I don't actually have
experience with that one since I didn't
do it and the bad Secretariat so if
you're thinking of starting company in
AR ml I wish you good luck and if for
any case you meet anyone here today
which company is making them work on
lead scoring or for the own thing I
think you should have them come talk to
me thank you very much
you talked about listening the customers
a lot and that sounds great but when you
add more customers you're gonna be
having models that you're trying to make
work for more use cases at some point
it's conceivable that you'll actually
lose performance maybe on some of the
earlier things that you were doing you
have any thoughts on how to maybe think
and plan for that yeah so it's very good
question and it definitely something
that comes up at the the later stage
ideally I think on this one you build in
you know you like taking the example for
us which is oh cool we have access to
Salesforce and in Salesforce we can see
the opportunity that I created you can
see if you know the models that were
predicted good create the you know
create more opportunity and you build
that into the model to get that feedback
loop and get it automated the
performance degradation is is tricky
effect well we were we build was a basic
dashboard that reports it and at some
point when it gets bad we retrain it
that was like that was the initial that
was the initial implementation and I
think that that's definitely a concern
Stephanie a concern or a stage yeah I'm
not sure I have like generalizable
advice but I think it's a very good very
good thing to keep an eye on and I think
the the the last I'm the two things that
I would come after this talk is okay now
which is the stage we went in after
those initial customers which is okay
now you need unit economics basically if
you have a data scientist training a new
model for every customers and it takes
them two weeks to come up with something
good it's gonna work for the first three
customers but not after that so you
definitely definitely when you want to
find those abstractions so that you can
get good economy neat economics on
training new models for new customers
and then it's maintaining them over time
I was like it's the performance still
good am i monitoring it am i
automatically retraining or manually
retraining and the third one which we
had to solve after this which then you
get into the Kafka and things like that
is deliverability
and performance of just delivering the
model in real time for example so
definitely what what would come after
after this step so you mentioned like
data part partners and with that was it
just that you integrated with a
Salesforce Marketo it wasn't like you
you signed a deal with Salesforce to
share the customer data that didn't
authenticate with you no no I was I mean
yeah in that case it was really existing
data sources that had good you know good
api's or a good way to share the data
okay so it was an integration it wasn't
I guess I wasn't confused with did you
like develop like a business partnership
with them to share data no not yeah and
especially with Salesforce I think they
don't want to talk to you until you have
you know something to you jack them
definitely about something that happens
afterwards rather like we today we
actually integrate in a lot of of
marketplaces so we're launching like one
five spot next week on intercom
Salesforce I think they're marketplaces
yeah I think we're asking too much rev
share upfront and we're like we don't
even know how much revenue this is going
to be we're not paying you ten thousand
dollars up front to be on your
marketplace but now it was really the
idea of they are they might be existing
source of data that your customers
already already as data in that you can
build on top of it's good to get started
I think after a while you get on the in
the decision that you may be seen as an
add-on to those things and then you
might want to be a I want to capture
that data myself directly but to get
started and sort of get through that
loop fast if you can find existing data
that is a really good really good thing
to do
my question is mainly on kind of
questions and ask you've probably got
from customers so it sounds like admit
CUDA you guys focused a lot on you know
third-party SAS ETL and then building
your models and delivery
customer value through that when you
know any of those customers that you
showed say you know we have really
meaningful data from trials that you
know deposited into our product database
our users database maybe other metadata
databases that they have that they want
to use for account based marketing or
whatever stuff just whatever internal
first party data how do you guys
approach integrating that you know each
yelling that in do you guys do things
like that and what's generally
approached with you know a non-standard
data model that you can expect from an
API that that is a very good question
that definitely something that advence
especially as you get to bigger
companies or older companies where we
approached it was say no early on I was
tricky I was like now we can do that
when we did cool ears and s free
endpoint can you please don't post a
file every day in this format I think we
tried that initially usually that stops
working after world the company's like
well no we can't do that just map it map
it yourself so what we did is just like
kind of same principle like make it
super easy for them to dump the data and
you either complexity from them so get
get the CSV file but you'll have you'll
have problems with that as well this is
like a fault that then basically that
means that like your data scientists or
data engineers would then transform that
integrate that into your overall data
models yeah so we did kind of the same
approach was like a the first three
customers just get the row as CSV dump
and do whatever you can with it and for
the four fifth one maybe now you're like
okay here's the data model I want the
data in or as an API endpoint that maybe
it's going to do some validation ahead
so you can scale that but I would say
initially my recommendation would be
just take whatever they send you as long
as you can load it you know as long as
this year is not corrupted you'll figure
it out later
you
[Music]